yo my biggest fear is now when i have to
stand
next to an old dude at a urinal and
listen to repeat
well some of you haven't heard that okay
i'll do my inheritance
my impersonation of an old tune peeing
out of here ready
[Laughter]
not laughing
[Laughter]
oh
[Laughter]
[Applause]
100
right and all of a sudden it sounds like
he throws 10 nickels into the urinal
[Laughter]
yeah i know what the [ __ ] it is
[Music]
you think i should do the medical
reasons at the end of my jokes that'll
help a lot
return to your medical journals
everybody let me tell you why this
happens
thank you for throwing some facts into
the jokes that always helps
okay because i'm not that
much younger than some of these dudes
first of all for those of you work out
you know that men hit a certain age in
the locker room
where they just decide [ __ ] it
i'm not wearing clothes anymore
oh an older dude probably around 65 and
old dude we'll straight up captain
morgan you right at your [ __ ]
how was your workout today can you get
your nuts out of my face i can't talk to
you right now dude
not on that an old dude will
and the nuts are long and they're great
one dude looked like he was dragging a
wizard behind him
[Laughter]
here
and i should've by the way i shouldn't
pay attention i had a conversation with
my grandfather when i was like oh
and i shouldn't pay attention
because he warned me
now my grandfather still to this day for
me top five funny person i remember my
mother this dude was just straight up
funny but he also had no
line of what was okay to say to a child
so we had a lot of weird conversations
you know
but this is my favorite one of all time
okay so
i'm eight
eight
you guys are me you're the back seat of
the car okay he sits down in the front
seat so this is all this is all i see
you guys are made i just see him go
and i go what happened he goes i just
sat on my nuts
i was like
my nuts are this thing i'm like
and he goes no it is wait so you get
older and you have to hold them in your
hand so you don't poop on them i was
like what the [ __ ]
why is this a conversation between us
after seeing these old dudes naked all
the time
my my idea about viagra and all that
[ __ ] has changed and i'll tell you why
after seeing this old dude's body and
i'm assuming women age the same way it's
not good for any of us here
i'm assuming we all age the same way and
i don't know if our genitals stopped
working
actually after seeing this older lady at
some point i just think two old people
stand in front of each other naked
i don't know if my dick works but my
[ __ ] eyes do so
come on pass on whatever that is
[Laughter]
getting
[Music]